[Engine starting].
>>Student: Look at
the thing roll, baby.
Smooth as a baby's bottom.
>>Narrator: For the past five
years, high schools from the islands
of Hawaii have designed and
built exotic electric vehicles,
and raced them in the
Electron Marathon.
The team from the West
Hawaii Explorations Academy
on the Big Island, has won the
race twice, and was gunning
for another title in 2001.
>>I'm driving it on our test
road, and to give you an idea
of what it's like,
bumpy, it's a little warm,
it's like a greenhouse in here.
>>Narrator: Each team
receives a kit with parts
like electric motors,
chains and sprockets.
They have to supply their own
batteries and other parts,
and can only spend 2,500 dollars
to design and build their car.
>>Quinn: This wheel is
mostly made by WHEA students.
We didn't make the spokes,
the nipples which are the little
spoke nuts, or the rim, however,
we did make the hub out of billet
aluminum rod, and then I assembled--
I put the spokes onto the rim and
tightened it all and trued it,
so it's all balanced,
so it won't wobble.
>>Narrator: The electric
car project is one
of five different projects
Quinn is involved with at WHEA.
>>Quinn: I enjoy having
a choice in what I do.
It's not just work sheets every
day, or something like that,
it's hands on, and it's fun stuff,
and it's good skills to have, also.
>>Narrator: One of WHEA's
secret weapons is Bill McKown,
a retired food executive who came up
with the idea for the granola bar.
>>Quinn: Why is it
sparking like that?
>>Bill: The capacitor is filling up.
>>Narrator: McKown now serves as
a mentor on several WHEA projects.
>>Bill: I got into helping out
the students with some projects,
and the main one that we do right
now, is an electric car project,
which sort of fits my background,
so it's very enjoyable for me,
to be able to give back some
of the skills that I have.
>>Quinn: This isn't really warm, so--
>>Bill: Yeah, right, but it
shouldn't be warm back here.
>>It's a very enjoyable thing to
be of service to other people,
and I find it hard to
imagine anything else
that could be more
enjoyable, frankly.
>>Narrator: In addition to
designing and building their cars,
each team must design and build a
website which accounts for 30 percent
of the team's total score.
They also have to give
an oral presentation
of the car building project.
Team members must answer one of three
questions they've drawn at random.
>>Student: There's three questions.
The first one is, what was the most
difficult problem, how was it solved?
The second one is, explain how math,
science and language arts
were integrated, and lastly,
what was the good and
bad of working together
and how did it help or hurt the team?
>>Announcer: The drivers are
psyched, the cars are ready,
so let's take a look at the field.
Car 911 is Castle High School.
>>Narrator: The race,
which featured 20 entrants,
is an energy efficiency
competition, rewarding the car
that completes the most laps.
>>Announcer: And Car Number Three,
is West Hawaii Explorations Academy.
The drivers are ready, the green
flag is out, and the race is on.
Waialua pulls out immediately
and leaves everyone in the dust.
Here comes Mid Pac, Car 11, and
Waiakea, Car 10, Castle in yellow,
then Kahuku, and finally, Kohala.
Amazing difference in body design.
>>Narrator: In the middle of
the race, it began to rain,
but the weather didn't
deter the WHEA car,
or the little green
machine from Kohala.
When the WHEA car pulled into the
pits for the mandatory driver change,
they discovered they
had some brake problems.
>>Student: Brake pod.
No, it's--
>>Student: Take the outside
curve like you taught us, okay?
Russell, watch this turn.
Go way to the outside.
>>Announcer: At the 40 minute mark,
Sacred Heart has abandoned its
body and left it in the pit.
They thought their body was rubbing
on something and slowing them down.
>>Narrator: In the end, West Hawaii's
sleek red machine fell four laps
short of the green
bug from Kohala High,
but the WHEA team will
be back next year
on a mission to recapture the cup.
>>Quinn: I feel that we've learned
from our mistakes from
last year's race.
We're going to work
on the car a lot more,
do the documentation a lot more,
and we're really raring
to get first place.
I really think we can do it.